do you think a documentary filmmaker
should have one hundred percent creative
control mmm he talked about earlier this
person Matt in your film and the mom
watched it and she was delighted because
that was Matt draw right that was him
right but there get to be a time when
certain subjects well-meaning
well-intentioned don't like certain
things that are said don't like the way
they look don't like the way they're
portrayed yeah in the end what do you or
in the beginning probably what are your
boundaries what do you tell them not so
really it's a great question I feel very
strongly that the filmmaker or
filmmakers really have to have final cut
in the film and for a lot of reasons
it's really hard to make one of these
with a committee it you're going to any
you can do it but I think you're going
to end up with something that's that's
really watered down and not very good so
I think having a really clear vision
who's telling this story and how do they
want to tell the story is is really
really important and we always demand
final cut with our films up you know of
our partners and our subjects and we
will not do a film unless we have that
but that said the kinds of films that we
tell you know I'm I would not consider
myself an investigative journalists for
example I'm not typically trying to
uncover deceitful activity or catch
people in a lie or catch people doing
things that they shouldn't be doing we
tend to the stories we tend to tell are
not like that that's not the kind of
stories were drawn to but we do invite
feedback from our subjects we do want to
know first of all if the story is
accurate and if we've made any mistakes
or factual mistakes and also you know
what in order to get a hundred percent
trust and confidence from your subjects
while you're making your film I think
they need to know that they could raise
a red flag before the film gets released
there may be something that we've
captured that we didn't even realize we
had captured that for whatever reason to
them it would be very painful if that
got out or would create a real problem
for them and we have taken feedback from
people and you know there are many cases
where we have allowed that sort of input
to affect our final cut but all that
aside we are not we don't we don't do
puff pieces and we don't do like PR
films I mean we do films that try to
capture the real story in if you build
it for instance Emily and Matt who are
the two teachers that are in the film I
mean they went through a really
difficult time together they were not
getting along now well together there
were some people in the town especially
the school board that were very
unsupportive all of that is in the film
and and you know no one who's familiar
with the story thinks that we tried to
gloss it over I mean there's a lot of
conflict in the film so you know if
someone says me I don't like how I look
there I I don't like what I said there
if it's if it rings true to us and there
isn't a real a compelling reason not to
include we leave it in the film and i
have to say we've had really great
relationships with the people we've
worked with all the way down the line I
mean like Will Shortz from word play
David Walker the Comptroller General the
United States who we did I oh USA with
Matt and Emily and the students from if
you build it I mean those people are all
I think they're all really proud of the
films that we made about them because
they're accurate and they're really
compelling and they're even entertaining
so I think that's important now if
you're let's say you're Michael Moore or
any other any number of investing
any number of joe berlinger of
investigative journalists that's
probably that's not going to be the case
because they're uncovering a lot of
things that make people look bad and I
mean they're good at doing that and
they're doing it for all the right
reasons so obviously they probably play
by a different set of rules and I think
we would probably play by a much
different set of rules when we decide to
tell a story like that which I'm sure
will do at some point in the future so
what's your talk like with these people
or is it in a contract I mean how do you
lay those ground rules out probably from
the beginning right yeah you really want
to get off on that right yeah no I you
know I really try to stay away from
contracts and a lot of legal
documentation I mean that that right
away gets people suspicious like what am
i what am I getting into here we just
talked to people we look them in the eye
and we tell them this is what we're
going to do we find you we think you're
really interesting we think you have a
great story we want to make a film about
you it's a film that we're going to make
about you we value your input will
certainly listen to your input but at
the end of the day it's our movie that
we're making about you and and if you if
you don't want to go along on the ride
then tell us now again I think the
easiest thing at least for us is people
look at our work and they know that we
don't we don't throw people under the
bus if once they deserve it the people
of the School Board of Bertie County
North Carolina comes off looking pretty
bad in our film and rightly so in fact I
think some people some people have told
us that we may be let them off a little
ease a little too easily but yeah we
you you know if you're going to spend a
year or two with someone and you're
going to devote a big part of your life
to telling their story and you're also
going to take their story and bring it
to a really wide audience I mean that's
that's a pretty important conversation
that you have to have and you have to
really develop some trust between each
other that you're going to do this
together and that it'll be something
that you'll all be proud of when it's
all done
you